that all the high road on the low road
of each sign the old Aries which is the
Piscean version was feisty and they'd
get angry a lot and they would find
themselves fighting just to fight they
couldn't control themselves and it came
with an impulse that at best they would
be super enthusiastic but it worse
they'd alienate people the the high road
of Aries now in the Aquarian age is to
fight for love and to say listen the
reason why I'm so pissed off is because
I care that is such a big departure from
the old make patriarchal version of
Aries the female version of Aries is I
love you so much
I will fight for this and I'm really
upset because I feel like we're separate
and we're pushing each other away and I
don't want to do that well now that's
the right use of fighting
let's do Taurus the old version of
Taurus was super materialistic they were
people that lived with fear around
sharing so they would hoard and they
would stick things in boxes and they
glue it down they turn the key because
they never trusted those people live
with a lot of fear the high road of
Taurus is to feel the gift of the stars
the Sun the Moon the plants the water
the everything is flowing here freely
and they begin to value the earth
element with trust so Buddha was a
Taurus
they really learn how to take a deep
breath look around and go you know what
I trust this place that's a very
involved Aquarion version of Taurus
versus the hoarder so they let go of
things and they learn the high power of
the Buddhist practice which is
non-attachment that would be the high of
Taurus the low and M&I needs to be so
nitty picking and gossiping and
everything was about the way they looked
and how they ate friends and the
Aquarian age the new of Gemini says out
loud if I'm talking too much will you
tell me and please understand that I
want us to be close I hope I'm not over
talking and they can even say I think I
interrupted you that's the evolved
Aquarian age Gemini who's aware that
their goal is to connect not to spread
words everywhere and become like
smothered by why does that person keep
talking the low road of cancer was they
were highly in love they're named after
a disease they were highly emotional and
they would feel it's the victimization
story the Piscean
of cancer was poor me no one loves me
I'm worried I don't feel safe here I
don't even like people the new version
is which is Dalai Lama is the best
example of the Aquarian version of
cancer he's a double cancer is to be in
so much trust but he meditates and he
prays every day so the highroad of
cancer is you become the healing agent
instead of being a victim you realize
your gift is to share and give
generously because you do self-care
because you know how to take care of
yourself and you're not a victim to oi
you won't believe what happened to me so
you become the positive just like the
dialogue doesn't complain about his
burry he prays he meditates he brings
people together and he lifts up the
energy
[Music]
you